good morning hey kids wait who the eff
is Hank Hank is a sentient Android from
the Star Trek The Next Generation
universe who as any true fan would know
is capable of reproduction because he
had a daughter anyway your video and
Monday was one of my favorite blog for
those videos ever but I can't believe
you got your Star Trek facts wrong right
so it's Tuesday I'm gonna upload this
tomorrow after spending all day flying
across the world with the baby but right
now it's Tuesday it's question Tuesday
the day that I answer real questions
from real nerdfighters do you have a
vegetable garden well this is my
backyard at the moment so no unless are
cigarette butts vegetables because if so
yes what's up with all the shoes and
feet in the foreign editions of your
books there are a lot of shoes and feet
in the foreign editions holy crap there
are a lot of shoes and feet in these
foreign editions I don't know what's up
with that did something happen with let
it snow yes take the movie rights to let
it snow just sold to Paramount a large
movie studio out there in Hollywood they
also own the movie rights to Looking for
Alaska which they have not yet made but
you never know maybe they'll make one of
them someday can Henny be in today's
video briefly during your stay have you
learned any Dutch going thing in a doc
what are some of the major differences
you've noticed between the US and Europe
well the biggest difference is that in
the u.s. 60% of bankruptcies are caused
by medical cost whereas in the
Netherlands 0% of bankruptcies are
caused by medical costs what's the title
of your new book is still not totally
decided believe it or not so I can't
tell you yet
but soon will you ever restart the
nerdfighter blurbing book club now
that's an idea I think it's summertime
you know what that means in
nerdfighteria it means wearing SPF 30
every time you go outside and reading
classic American literature for fooling
Hank I hereby announce that the new book
in the nerdfighter blurbing book club is
none other than the great gatsby by f
scott Fitzgerald there's a link to
purchase the book in the doobly-doo
although if you don't live in the United
States it's probably public domain and
you can download it for free regardless
it's cheap it's possible you've already
read this book and maybe you even hated
it but that's because you weren't
reading it with me so whether you're
reading it for the first time or reading
it again that's our book let's read it
the great gatsby what are you gonna get
Pizza John shirts back in my size now
BAM I just did it dftba.com slash pizza
I am here to solve your problems how do
i best confront the urge toward nihilism
well not that kind of problem your
smaller problems you know pizza shirt
related problems what is the name of the
hospital you were born in asked to the
identity Heath there's the Yeti
dftba shirts yes but infuriating ly she
refuses to wear Pizza John shirt because
she thinks it's creepy I don't know
what's so creepy about it never eat
pizza again her never got one the one
where I can still eat pizza
what's Hanks punishment Hank I've chosen
the punishment that was most popular in
nerdfighteria and that is humpy Hank all
over town I don't know why nerdfighters
want to see that but apparently they do
so that's your punishment hump the town
what are your thoughts on tumblr my
thoughts I think it's the number one
destination on the internet for images
of Paula Deen riding me do you think
benign dictatorships are a good form of
government to be honest I think benign
dictatorship is a bit of an oxymoron
who's your biggest inspiration you I
know that's cheesy but it's also the
truth I write books and make videos
because I am inspired by you to try to
tell you stories that will be
interesting and hopefully kind of
helpful I've seen my own life change by
books and honestly there's just no
greater inspiration than the opportunity
to do that for other people when
teachers say the author means do you
really mean those things yeah probably
but in my opinion teachers shouldn't say
that because one teachers aren't really
in the business of reading authors minds
and two and more importantly what
authors mean doesn't really matter I
don't think what's important is that
critical reading can be a way into
thinking quite deeply about questions
that are difficult and complicated and
not in some like boring and abstract way
like oh and Moby Dick white is a symbol
for nature's ambivalence to man but
instead in a concrete and totally
interesting way like nature's complete
indifference to you as expressed by the
color white in Moby Dick is something
that you had better get your head around
or else you're going to end up like
Captain Ahab so it's not so much about
uncovering secret mysteries for the sake
of uncovering secret mysteries it's
about using story as a way into thinking
about our actual lives and how we're
actually living them and that's how
we're gonna try to read The Great Gatsby
Hank I'm gonna go pack I will see you on
Friday